imagine whatever this bad circumstance
is happening once an hour every day for
the next year how would you feel on the
2,000th time of that happening by that
point if you really thought about it
you'd probably just be like well this is
just how this is this is how life is and
then you wouldn't be upset by it because
you just adjusted your expectations if
your boss was always short with you
every hour of every day in a year it
wouldn't upset you because you would
expect that a lot of the anxiety the
sadness the anger whatever it is it
comes from the fact that our
expectations are unmet and so either we
can demand that an uncaring Universe
changes to meet us or we can change our
expectations